Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The research field of image translation with
the aid of learning algorithms has been on
fire lately.
For instance, this earlier technique would
look at a large number of animal faces, and
could interpolate between them, or in other
words, blend one kind of dog into another
breed.
But that’s not all, because it could even
transform dogs into cats, or create these
glorious plump cats and cheetahs.
The results were absolutely stunning, however,
it would only work on the domains it was trained
on.
In other words, it could only translate to
and from species that it took the time to
learn about.
This new method offers something really amazing:
it can handle multiple domains, or multiple
breeds, if you will, even ones that it hadn’t
seen previously.
That sounds flat out impossible, so let’s
have a look at some results.
This dog will be used as content, therefore
the output should have a similar pose, but
its breed has to be changed to this one.
But there is one little problem.
And that problem is that the AI has never
seen this breed before.
This will be very challenging because we only
see the head of the dog used for style.
Should the body of the dog also get curly
hair?
You only know if you know this particular
dog breed, or if you are smart and can infer
missing information by looking at other kinds
of dogs.
Let’s see the result.
Incredible.
The remnants of the leash also remain there
in the output results.
It also did a nearly impeccable job with this
bird, where again, the style image is from
a previously unseen breed.
Now, this is, of course, a remarkably difficult
problem domain, translating into different
kinds of animals that you know nothing about
apart from a tiny, cropped image, this would
be quite a challenge, even for a human.
However, this one is not the first technique
to attempt to solve it, so let’s see how
it stacks up against a previous method.
This one is from just a year ago, and you
will see in a moment how much this field has
progressed since then.
For instance, in this output, we get two dogs,
which seems to be a mix of the content and
the style dog.
And, while the new method still seems to have
some structural issues, the dog type and the
pose is indeed correct.
The rest of the results also appear to be
significantly better.
But what do you think?
Did you notice something weird?
Let me know in the comments below.
And now, let’s transition into image interpolation.
This will be a touch more involved than previous
interpolation efforts.
You see, in this previous paper, we had a
source and a target image, and the AI was
asked to generate intermediate images between
them.
Simple enough.
In this case, however, we have not two, but
three images as an input.
There will be a content image, this will provide
the high-level features, such as pose, and
its style is going to transition from this
to this.
The goal is that the content image remains
intact while transforming one breed or species
into another.
This particular example is one of my favorites.
Such a beautiful transition, and surely not
all, but many of the intermediate images could
stand on their own.
Again, the style images are from unseen species.
Not all cases do this well with the intermediate
images, however.
We start with one eye because the content
and this style image have one eye visible,
while the target style of the owl has two.
How do we solve that?
Of course, with nuclear fission.
Look!
Very amusing.
Loving this example, especially how impossible
it seems because the owl is looking into the
camera with both eyes, while, we see its backside
below the head.
If it looked to the side, like the input content
image, this might be a possibility, but with
this contorted body posture, I am not so sure,
so I’ll give it a pass on this one.
So there you go, transforming one known animal
into a different one that the AI has never
seen before.
And it is already doing a more than formidable
job at that.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!